this video was made possible by Wix
build your website easily at wix.com
slash go slash Wendover this is a 737
max a brand new airplane almost it has a
few aspects that makes it unique
most modern airplanes have electronic
preflight check lists the 737 max uses
paper checklists most modern airplanes
can be turned on by flipping a switch
the 737 max uses a seven step process
most modern airplanes have electronic
on-screen warnings describing exactly
what a problem is the 737 max only has a
warning light most modern airplanes are
fully fly-by-wire meaning their ailerons
and elevators and other flight control
surfaces move by electronic signals
triggering servo motors the 737 max has
running from the cockpit physical cables
themselves pulling most of the flight
control surfaces to move not all these
design elements are necessarily bad
things many pilots in fact prefer the
flyby cable system for example but there
is one other big difference between most
modern airplanes and the 737 max most
modern airplanes are flying up above
right now the 737 max is not these
design elements are all indicators of a
truth about the 737 max it's a 50 year
old airplane retooled re-engined and
redesigned three times to make it what
it is today it is the oldest major
commercial plane type still being made
today and it shows much of the design of
the 737 max was done by people not even
alive today
the reason Boeing revamped and revamped
and revamped this airplane over and over
and over again has to do with the
economics of the aviation industry as a
whole and one of the world's fiercest
rivalries Boeing versus Airbus back in
2011 rumblings were emerging that Boeing
would design an all-new single-aisle
airplane to replace the rather old 737
it seemed like the logical choice that
would allow the manufacturer to design a
far more efficient aircraft
unconstrained by the 737s old metallic
airframe and technologies
the reason Boeing might not have chosen
to scrap the 737 earlier though is
because two Airlines fuel efficiency
matters less for their short haul planes
that's partially just because small
planes fly fewer hours per day among
American Airlines for example the
average small narrow-body plane spends
eight point two hours airborne per day
while the average wide-body planes
spends 11.5 hours airborne meanwhile
though the average small narrow-body
plane flies 4.5 flights per day whereas
the average wide-body flies just 1.5 per
day considering small planes fly shorter
routes they spend more time on the
ground unloading and loading between
flights so with fewer hours per day in
the air the proportion of cost to vote
as a fuel is lower to operate small
planes than big planes traditionally
airlines would rather have a cheap small
plane rather than an expensive super
efficient small plane the 737 is just
that is a cheap small plane b737 700 s
less price is only 89 million dollars
and once airlines actually negotiate an
order the real price is far less with
over 50 years of experience Boeing has
perfected the 737 manufacturing process
and is therefore able to offer the plane
at a relatively cheap price at their
peak Boeing was making one 737 every
fourteen hours so in summary when
prioritizing which planes to buy
airlines are going to be more focused on
upgrading their long-haul y body fleets
to the newest most fuel-efficient
airplanes than their small planes in the
past decade or so though airlines have
been changing how they've been using
narrow body planes planes like the 737
a320 and 757 have long been the core of
almost any airlines ashore all fleet but
they've started to be used for longer
and longer flights these smaller planes
are cheaper to operate and have been
getting redesigned with longer and
longer range which allow airlines to
operates longer routes with less demand
that just couldn't fail a larger white
body plane the fleet age of United's
planes for example indicates just this
you can see that the average age of most
of their narrow body fleet is from the
late 1990s and early 2000s while much of
their wide-body fleet was put into
service in the current decade but going
back to what's changed you can see that
with small narrow body planes over the
past 20 years these planes are flying
fewer and fewer flights per day while
being airborne for more and more hours
per day meaning they're flying longer
and longer routes in addition in 2011
when Boeing was deciding what to do next
with the 737 program
jet fuel prices had reached close to an
all-time high so airlines were more
concerned than ever about fuel
efficiency even for their smaller planes
therefore the fuel efficiency of these
small narrow-body planes was and is
becoming more and more important that in
addition to a general need to improve
efficiency over time was why boeing was
looking to create an all-new narrow-body
airplane but then reality hit on
December 1st 2010 Airbus announced that
it would release a reengineer a320
family aircraft the a320neo
unfortunately for Boeing the a320neo
sold quite well in its first few months
it was clear that Airlines wanted a more
efficient small plane and fast
soon after something worse happened
American Airlines which was at the time
one of the world's largest airlines had
no Airbus planes in 2011 all of their
long-haul fleet and most of their short
haul fleet was built by Boeing on July
20th 2011 though American announced a
massive order for 460 narrow-body planes
130 Airbus a320s 130 Airbus a320neo
100 737s and 100 re-engined 737s the
press release said American intends to
order 100 of Boeing's expected new
evolution of the 737ng with a new engine
that would offer even more significant
fuel efficiency gains over today's
models at this point this rienne
Jeanette announced American announced an
order for a non-existent plane they
strong-armed Boeing in to re-engining
their 737 rather than building a new
airplane by dangling an order of this
hypothetical revamped airplane over them
it's likely that Boeing had already
agreed internally to re engine the plane
but nonetheless why would American do
that why would they want a less
efficient less modern re-engined 737
over a more modern more efficient
brand-new narrow-body plane well in
short it's because fuel cost is far from
all the cost pilots are generally
trained to operate just one type of
aircraft some fly the a380 some fly the
triple 7 some fly the a320 and some fly
the 737 but they don't fly these 730
and 700 or 737-800 or 737-900 they fly
the 737 airplane as a whole pilots are
trained to the aircraft not the specific
aircraft variant in general pilots can
and do switch between variants of
aircraft even in any given day and are
not required to do any substantial
training to be certified on different
aircraft variants crucially the FAA has
never required that 737 pilots complete
any simulator training before flying new
737 variants
that's because a 50 year old 737 more or
less flies like a one-year-old 737
American wanted a refreshed 737 over a
new plane since they already had
thousands of trained and certified 737
pilots they had no pilots for a
hypothetical new narrow-body Boeing and
the cost of training their pilots to a
new plane would be massive even ignoring
the training cost though it's far
cheaper for airlines to just have one
large fleet of one type of aircraft
rather than a few smaller fleets of
different aircraft
that's why budget airlines like Ryanair
easyJet and Southwest each operate only
one aircraft type it costs less to just
have one group of pilots and mechanics
that can work on all the planes and
that's why most airlines try to have as
few different aircraft types as possible
so soon after Americans order
announcement Boeing officially announced
the 737 max this aircraft would be 15
percent more fuel efficient than the
previous 737 model and would therefore
have a maximum range of 4,400 miles or 7
thousand 100 kilometers compared to the
old 737 34 hundred mile or 5,400
kilometer range this would make it
easily possible to operate transatlantic
flights on this small narrow body plane
airlines did end up taking advantage of
this range to operate long yet low
demand routes for example Air Canada
operated transatlantic flights from
Halifax and st. John's to London
Heathrow using the 737 max Norwegian
Airlines flew them as far as Newburgh
New York to Bergen Norway goal airlines
meanwhile broke records with their daily
737 max flight all the way from Brasilia
Brazil to Miami Florida an up to eight
hour flight to achieve the fuel
efficiency and range improvements that
made these flights possible though
Boeing had to make a crucial change to
the air
they had to fit bigger engines without
getting too much into the engineering
the newest most efficient engines are
all physically larger than those of the
past due to designs that have more air
bypass and flow past the engine core the
problem though was that the 737 design
was quite low to the ground back 50
years ago when the aircraft was designed
this was a conscious choice it was a
feature that made it easy to load bags
without a conveyor belt and maintain
engines without a lift
this simplified operating to many of the
less developed airports of that time the
proximity to the ground was no problem
for the first generation of 737 and long
and thin engines that looked like this
for the second generation though the 737
classic boeing moved the engine further
forward and up and designed its intake
as non-circular to achieve more ground
clearance the next generation also kept
this design but then for the 737 max
they just had to fit an even larger
engine so they put it even further
forward and up in addition to adding
eight inches or 20 centimeters to the
nose gear these changes though changed
the aerodynamics of the plane and
therefore how it handled it would cause
the plane to pitch up more than the last
generation which would put it at a
greater risk of stalling so they
installed a system called MCAS
the maneuvering characteristics
augmentation system this system would
activate when it sense the aircraft's
angle of attack was too high and would
automatically rotate the horizontal
stabilizer to cause the aircraft's nose
to pitch down the aircraft figures out
its angle of attack though three sensor
and if this sensor is broken it can
cause the aircraft to think it is flying
at too high of an angle and self-correct
unless the system is deactivated it can
keep pitching the aircraft down until
the ground it is this that is believed
to have been the cause of the crash of
Lion Air flight 610 in October 2018 and
the crash of Ethiopian Airlines flight
302 in March 2019 and it is these that
led to the grounding of every single 737
max in the world boeing found itself
back in 2011 in a position where it had
to choose between the easy wrong or the
difficult right you had to choose
between short term and long term gain
and it chose to win
he chose to push the limits of an old
design to a point where required
correction upon correction to even make
it the same plane given the storm of
economic pressures surrounding the
company in 2011 though Boeing's
investors would not have been happy if
the company embarked on a long expensive
new aircraft design process while Airbus
engulfed Marcus share with her a320neo
nobody would have guessed at the time
with the company and aircrafts
phenomenal safety record that the
decision would lead to a potentially
faulty plane nobody would have guessed
that the decision would potentially cost
hundreds of lives
it was a hasty decision made by hasty
human brains and for that Boeing and its
737 program will suffer long term
possibly permanent consequences
I've just redone the when over
productions website with Wix which was a
great simple and quick process one of
the things I like about Wix is that they
have a few different ways that you can
make your site depending on your
experience level and how much time you
want to take you could have them make it
for you using their artificial design
intelligence you can make you yourself
using the Wix editor or for the
experienced you can code your websites
easily with a bunch of extra features
using their corvid system personally I
use the Wix editor and was able to
quickly make a site that I think looks
quite good they're designer templates
and drag-and-drop website builder made
it quite easy Wix is paid plans are all
quite reasonably priced and even include
a custom domain name but you can start
building your website today for free at
wix.com slash go slash Wendover